more on the escalating tension on the
Korean Peninsula and with Venezuela
we're joined from our Washington bureau
by Douglas 11 he's a senior fellow at
New America Foundation and a former
director at the National Security
Council Douglas good morning morning I
think we heard the president say we're
locked and loaded
have we been locked and loaded in fact
for a while when it comes to North Korea
absolutely the United States and
military the Army in particular has been
on hair-trigger alert on that border for
over 60 years now so if there's a fight
tomorrow the ultimate outcome is not in
any serious doubt the United States and
their South Korean allies will win that
fight but the level of collateral damage
and civilian devastation would be huge
the Pentagon says that it's going to go
ahead in South Korea with the military
exercises that were planned what's the
impact that that might have
I'm sure the North Koreans will be
unhappy with it but this is the flipside
of being prepared to fight tonight or
tomorrow you have to do these exercises
you have to make sure that the two
allies know how to fight together that
everyone is prepared we have one of our
best generals there in theater Vince
Brooks the four-star is the real deal
one of the smartest generals the Army
has he does know what he's doing
this exercise needs to happen just how
effective is our missile defense system
how accurate is it and and what are the
potential drawbacks if we have to use it
well the the fed system did have a very
successful test this summer it is
accurate but on the other hand it's not
something you want to bet the farm on if
there's a nuclear missile coming it is
accurate but it is not foolproof and if
several missiles are coming at some
point the system gets overwhelmed Chuck
we also heard from the President on
Venezuela not ruling out a military
option I don't know how else to ask this
other than what was the president
thinking I think he's giving a reminder
I'm sure everyone in the region
remembers that almost 30 years ago we
did overthrow a government in the region
in Panama this is a this is not unheard
of for the United States to intervene
in the region now on the other hand we
had much less success with you know
Nicaragua and Cuba so our record in the
region is mixed but I think the
president is reminding that in an
increasingly unstable situation if
Venezuela is clearly on a downward
spiral that this is the United States
backyard and we have very real interests
in the region
Douglas Oliphant thank you that my
pleasure